I have something simultaneously
fascinating and very very scary for you
we've covered before when Donald Trump's
brain seems to glitch these moments
where he simultaneously gets confused
about what he's saying radically changes
topic but at the same time has this
visible physical twitch it happens in
his shoulders this happened a few times
now and it happened yesterday during
Donald Trump's rally in Wildwood New
Jersey but with an added quirk this time
you could actually hear what sounds like
a Fox News host on a hot mic unable to
control their laughter about what Donald
Trump is doing and then immediately
foxnews jumps in and cuts away from the
rally when Donald Trump's brain appears
to glitch that big a brain of his as he
likes to say check it out you'll hear
Trump do that neurologically
questionable stutter and shake and
change topic and then you'll hear a
laugh and then you'll hear Fox News jump
in Democrats decided to shield and
shelter look look wait you have
criminals all right watching the
president here in Wildwood New Jersey I
just wanna get a quick comment before we
toss it over to chuck or Molly Hemingway
so let's watch and listen to it one more
time
Trump's ranting about Democrats and
crime or something the brain glitch
happens it sounds like an old cassette
tape melting almost and then you hear a
Fox News host laughs and then they cut
away immediately from it
Democrats decided to shield and shelter
look look wait you have criminals all
right watching the president here in
Wildwood New Jersey I just wanna get a
quick comment before we toss it over to
Tucker Molly have anyone it seems that
even at Fox News they are realizing that
this is not normal remember another
recent instance of this while Trump was
speaking to the right-wing group turning
points USA this happened
and let me begin by wishing you a
beautiful like look you remember this do
you remember they were trying to take
Christmas it's almost as if you imagine
a vinyl record is playing on a term
turntable and someone walks up to it and
just sort of spins it and you hear some
scratching and then it picks up on
another spot like they just move the
turntable and then there's a you're at
another point in the song so to speak if
you go to google.com right now as of
this morning anyway and you type in
untreated syphilis you will now see a
picture of Donald Trump when you google
untreated syphilis this is of course the
work of internet trolls who have made
that happen
but that is a phrase that is
increasingly being mentioned back to Fox
News cutting away from this remember
that the network now cutting away from
Donald Trump's brain glitches is very
much of a contrast given that they were
signal boosting Hillary Clinton has
Parkinson's type stories back in 2015
and 2016 I heard this morning from a
neurologist who asked not to be
identified who said this did to him
looks like some kind of frontotemporal
dementia now that's an umbrella term
it's an umbrella term for a group of
conditions that start to cause nerve
loss in the brain's frontal lobes and it
tends to get worse over time sometimes
it worsens roughly at the rate that
we're seeing it at least publicly with
Donald Trump and the neurologist who
wrote to me said if this continues it
will be very difficult for Donald Trump
to coherently debate whoever is the
Democratic nominee in August or
September or whenever the debates are in
the fall he would likely be more
impaired by then also certain
medications like antidepressants often
SSRIs they can be used in the short term
to stave off some of the symptoms of
this type of decline again we are just
speculating I know and that is all that
neurologists and mental health
professionals are able to do because
Donald Trump will not actually subject
himself to a proper screening for what
it is that is going on here so yet again
one of those very strange what it
some are calling it a neurological
glitch some are calling it of
colloquially a brain short-circuit it's
unusual it's odd Trump looks visibly
confused and physically shakes when it
happens it's a question mark and we're
all just trying to figure it out if you
enjoy shows like Shark Tank or you're
fascinated by entrepreneurs and how they
become successful I've got something
really cool for you to check out the
YouTube channel we're partnering with
called up flip and you can find it at
david pakman.com slash up flip it's a
new channel they're hitting the ground
running with really excellent content
they're uploading new videos all the
time in each video you meet a different
entrepreneur and take an in-depth look
at how they built their business from
the ground up you can examine the
business up close learn their strategies
for success see what it's like to live a
day in their shoes as an entrepreneur
myself I find this stuff endlessly
interesting I love learning about how
business owners got to where they are
what motivates them what the turning
points were and everyone who's featured
in up flips videos have their own really
cool insights to share but it's content
that's really easy to appreciate even if
you don't have your own business every
entrepreneur on up flip has their own
story to tell they're all fascinating
check it out if you watch my show check
out up flip this is part of a
partnership we're doing with them
they're friends of ours I think you'll
really enjoy their content it's really a
different it's unique there's something
for everybody check it out subscribe to
their channel at david pakman.com slash
up flip